[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q a number
87 sorry for the long delay we were
waiting for
odyssey to update we've alerted them to
the problem
anyway hopefully that will be a
shortened process in the future
indeed we are ready for questions and
answers
yes we are so we're we are gonna do this
abbreviated um because man it's late
it's been a long
it's been a long number of things dta
do this abbreviated
usually you're better at acronyms
yes and jokes but it's late that's the
thing is this is a comparatively late
stream
it is jokes they've suffered it is yes
all right
there have been wow there have been
multiple recent reports from the u.s
media stating that 99.8 percent of new
cover deaths are in the unvaccinated
the claims of about 99 are not even
close to the data we have in the uk
where a significant number of coba
deaths are in vaccinated people for
obvious reasons they are the most
vulnerable
thoughts so i mean i think this is a
question
about well we could read it one of two
ways right like
that's a big inconsistency why would
there be an inconsistency or
is this so clearly not likely
that we should be reading this as
monkeying with the baseline
well let me say one
it is impossible to know it is possible
that different
populations are going to have different
effects based on different
variants different vaccination schemes
something is clearly going to happen
where
vaccination has an impact on the
emergence of variants those
variants may well affect those who are
unvaccinated
more profoundly and the vaccines do seem
to have an
impact on the severity of disease so
anyway
i think it is very important two things
are very important one not to leap to
conclusions about what
means what and i do believe that the
unvaccinated are going to
be blamed for what is going to happen no
matter what yeah we're already seeing
that
um but the other thing is if there's one
overarching lesson to covid it is
that our inability to figure out just
simply what is happening to measure
obvious things and see whether they go
up or down in response to this or that
this inability to know who is sick with
covet who has not had covet
is appalling and um in addition to
figuring out how to
get our perverse incentives straightened
out so they don't interfere
with public health policy we absolutely
have to figure out
how to get our basic uh information
collection apparatus
clear so that we can sort real paradoxes
from
nonsense that arises just out of low
quality measures
and self-sabotage
yeah very good i am getting no shortage
of snark regarding lab lake and
ivormectin
any ideas for a one-year bet that would
be unambiguously collectible on both
sides
well this is in its own way exactly the
same question as the last one
yeah and what i would say is i think we
all ought to be
quite frightened about the fact that
what is actually true
does not necessarily come to dominate
the narrative and i'm watching this i've
watched it now twice with lab leak where
lab leak was officially portrayed as
nonsense
and then the official story made a
transition for no obvious reason
there was no new information and now
it's going in the reverse direction
where
people are feeling emboldened to
challenge it again and
the problem is this is not evidentiary
this is something about
you know some team sport in which ideas
rise and fall
having nothing to do with what the
evidence points to
and so anyway i i don't have any
confidence that
we will ultimately have the story and
that thereby
if you bet in the right direction you
will collect
right and you know that's a huge
red flag if we can't figure out what's
true if we cannot
you know upon discovery of evidence of
something
lock it in so that we cannot be made to
forget that it existed
um then we are in serious trouble
we are but do like i'm i admit that i'm
just i'm
kind of fried at this point but i don't
think there was an operational thing in
there
oh that's the point yeah and my point is
because there is no
obvious way to bet so that your clearer
insight or
failure of it can be manifest
in gains or losses yeah that tells you
where we are we are in
pure narrative land well i guess um
this isn't an answer but um apropos
something that uh
we have talked about in the past and
that you in particular have
have spoken to in a number of places
um keeping yourself honest and keeping
your
interlocutors come honest uh by
yourself writing down what you currently
think and putting it in something
sealed and dated and asking them to do
the same
and you know in terms of a bet maybe
being like okay we're gonna like we're
gonna
we've got these things and now we're
gonna give them to a third party or you
know put like something right
and come back to them and enlighten them
of
whatever it is and you know and perhaps
ask you know yourself and the person
that you would be betting with
um to write down you know a sentence
on each of the things that you think are
true and like we're being
vague about what those things might be
but um
comparing your position now
and their position now to what is what
we all understand to be true
in a year should be revealing
at least with regard to the lab leak and
ivermectin
i hope that there will be more clarity
on both
yeah we can hope and you know that's why
we are taking the risk that we're taking
is
to force the conversation to uh reveal
what's going on and you know frankly it
worked with lab leak
and then it sort of is unworking right
it's it's an amazing
and amazing fact um on the other but at
least you know with ivermectin
precisely because you made this point
but i i wanted to circle back around and
just like hammer it but you made this
point in the first hour in the first two
hours
um that you know the the the vaccine
only and for everyone
people are you know actually like
really speaking from weird privilege
like it's it and you said americans but
i was thinking like i think
berlinsky's in europe and layman's in
australia
and dagon is in russia and that's
weird-ish
um but you know so this this the
privileged place
of the effectively western educated
industrialized rich democratic world
that is going to have access to the
vaccines
um is um is showing like
all y'all's privilege is showing when
you imagine this
that every that ivermectin needs to be
quashed and
mocked and you know no off label use
should ever be used
when you know people in
yogyakarta and timbuktu
and tana and you know all these other
places
may not have access to your damn
vaccines and they could have access to
ivermectin in some of those cases they
already have had access to ivermectin
so well but um so i think the privilege
thing is right
but the other point is you're actually
shooting yourself in the foot
right if you want vaccines
to create herd immunity sufficient that
you can go back to your regular life and
not worry about kova then you need to
worry about all the people who can't get
it or won't get it right
yeah so the point is it's not even it's
not a privilege that makes sense right
there's privilege that's obnoxious
yeah that's toxic but that makes sense
when somebody
you know i mean from like a selfish
perspective right make sense if
you know if the school your kid goes to
is great and
you happen not to be moved by the fact
that the kids
you know in the next zip code over go to
a crappy school
that's gross but it makes sense
it does not make sense for you to be
pushing for
herd immunity and telling people they're
bad for not getting vaccines if your
plan even if it got to everybody that
you're reaching would not drive this
thing extinct because the point is
you're still going to be you know on
this in this situation where we don't
reach hurt immunity
it doesn't go extinct and so then
because it's not reaching all these
other people who don't have access to
the vaccines absolutely not you're not
just talking about the
because the vaccines are themselves
imperfect again a term of art but
because they won't reach
a lot of places even if they were
perfect yeah we'd have this problem and
so the real the real point
that even a technically perfect vaccine
needs to be uh needs to get to 100 of
the people
well no it needs to get to whatever it
needs to get to a large fraction of the
people
but um and and so this is really you
know if there's a difficult
but really important message it's that
if your position is ivermectin doesn't
work and these vaccines are great
that sounds like talking points on
somebody's presentation that does not
sound like a natural position
yeah right and you should ask yourself
if i followed that position to its
logical conclusion would i be free of
covet two years from now and that you
know i think
um i think that partially
explains um why we are in fact seeing
um ivermectin being used you know
somewhat surreptitiously and somewhat
not
in countries that have you know plenty
of infrastructure and such but don't
have
as you know places in countries that are
poorer and
and um perhaps just don't have the
wherewithal to bring the massive
vaccination program
in yeah and yeah it's just it's more
expensive among other things
all right
if you took the vax while also taking
ivor mekden would the vax be effective
that is an excellent question that shows
that whichever student this was has been
paying attention
well she shares a name with one of our
students with several of our students
actually so maybe all right
awesome awesome um here's what i would
tell you is
we don't know the answer to that
question the reason that we don't know
the answer to that question is because
there are multiple mechanisms of action
that appear to be involved
in the effectiveness of ivermectin and i
think the question
hinges on whether or not binding spike
protein
is an actual important effect of the
drug which it may well be
that would explain there's something
there's a paper that finds that but if i
remember correctly
um dr malone was not compelled by it
yeah i think nobody is certain
and because nobody is certain it is
speculative
now certainly somebody should figure it
out well i mean
there was a paper that came out well but
what we need is
i believe it's not like there's no work
that's been done
it's not like someone is just being like
oh i think it might it's like well there
was work that was done it was published
i would have to go back to it and to
figure out why uh
it is not uh regarded as conclusive it's
possible that it is
stronger evidence than i think but
anyway it is possible that it binds to
spike protein it is possible that it
doesn't it clearly has
at least one other mode of interaction
or mode of action and
possibly more and actually that's one of
the
fascinating things about many
of these natural compounds so
um things often have many effects
and why that is the case is worth
exploring
but that it appears to be the case you
know that a an anti-parasitic drug
appears to have
anti-viral action is in and of itself
fascinating right why you know is that a
lucky coincidence or is there some
deep story about the molecule in this
soil bacterium that is interacting with
multiple systems
in the soil that would explain that
naturally it would be wonderful to know
that natural history story and i'm
pretty sure we don't yep
um yeah but i
i think you said this if it does if
ivermectin does bind the spike protein
um and you were on ivermectin when you
got the vaccine
it's likely to render the effects of the
vaccine
it's likely to neutralize them at least
largely both the positive effects on the
negative effects
um so potentially
i think that you know if if ivermectin
binds the spike protein um that
taking the ivermectin
later after the vaccine has had a chance
to do
its uh to have its good effects um
could potentially clear any remaining
spike protein
that was in your system yeah if it works
that way if it works
and if we were to able if we were able
to nail down that it didn't work that
way
it had no interaction with the spike
protein but did
positively uh affect health
in terms of post-vaccine syndrome and
things like that
you could imagine a world right if you
if you showed
that it allowed immunity to develop
but successfully uh blocked some of the
harmful effects of vaccine then it could
actually compensate for some of the
defects of these vaccines
wow yeah synergistic right and so the
point is
wouldn't you want to know i mean i would
yeah i do
yeah i do
what are your thoughts on the insanely
disproportionate lockdowns in the uk on
australia where most are people
vaccinated and cases
and deaths are low well yeah to the
degree that the lockdowns are
are persisting or i think in at least i
think in the uk they're persisting
like here in oregon we're finally open
like just
as of not that long ago but in australia
i think they came back right like
australia's now in winter
and they they it they went back into
lockdown i want to
take this opportunity to make two points
okay one
there is i believe genuine reason to
worry that
certain restrictions are
being used for social reasons not for
epidemiological reasons and
we can point specifically to all of the
instructions about
using masks outdoors right that was
nonsense from an epidemiological
perspective
and it should not have happened and we
don't know
when lockdowns are being used for some
reason that has nothing to do with
epidemiology
however epidemiologically speaking we
are playing a very dumb game
right we impose restrictions and then
rates begin to drop for whatever reason
we relax the restrictions
and then rates begin to climb and the
basic point is
r sub f needs to be below one and stay
there
long enough to drive the
the pathogen to extinction and if you
could do it
locally if you could do it in your state
right
that would be an accomplishment it would
not be a permanent accomplishment if
the next state over didn't do it but
let's say one state got good at this
let's say oklahoma decided you know what
we're saying this we are going to come
up with a regime that actually
successfully drives it to
extinction or near extinction inside of
oklahoma and then we're going to hope
that nebraska notices
right something like that might be
easier if hawaii tried it
hawaii has a better has a better shot
it can wag its finger at people at the
airport for example
um but but there is a problem
in that our sense of relief you know
it's like somebody who
diets and when they see the number they
want on the scale feels like ah
eureka and then they go eat and it's
like well okay so
you know it's going to be that yeah yep
good um do either of you have any
updated insights on the novovax vaccine
i hear it's i hear that it's good that
it could be safer
do you have any outstanding concerns you
know i don't
i don't know i i have not
looked into it recently enough to have a
sense of
i've looked into it yeah i would say
um a priori it looks better
there's one way in which it's clearly
worse which is that it's newer
so we don't know right we know less
about how it works on the other hand how
much we actually know about how
the current vaccines work is debatable
because in some sense we're not
collecting the data in a systematic way
and we're fighting over
the data that we do have and what it
means and so it's very hard to compare
i would point out that the term safe is
a problem
because safe you know if you go back
through the logic that we've
talked about here on the podcast safe
and doesn't do harm are two different
things right the unloaded gun
may not do harm if you pull the trigger
while pointing it at yourself
but it doesn't mean it's safe to do it
right so that distinction
means um there's one way in which the
novovax
vaccine can't be safe because we don't
know what its impact is and it has the
same critique that we made of these
other vaccines early on which is that we
know nothing about their long-term
effects
that said i do think one thing that we
should be
hoping for is a traditional vaccine
that works against covid and is perfect
and
one other thing that i never hear
mentioned just
never hear it is what is the opportunity
cost of vaccinating people
with the current imperfect vaccines
what does it do to our ability to induce
a better immunity later with a different
vaccine
maybe it doesn't interfere with it maybe
we are actually signing up
for a prototype and the thing downstream
that's much better
becomes not very useful because
vaccinating twice has some paradoxical
effect
i don't know but i'd at least like to
hear that conversation
well um i mean among the vaccines that
are available now
i've begun to hear it recommended by
various health agencies
that um that it both that you can mix it
up
and in some cases that you should mix it
up and i haven't seen the explanation
for why they think you should
but it would seem to me that that logic
should be generalizable should be
generalizable if it is true that
taking one dose of pfizer and a second
dose of
excuse me moderna or a j j and then
topping off with pfizer you know
whatever it is that people are
recommending
if that actually might confer greater
immunity than either of those vaccines
alone
um that it also suggests that there's
not
a greater safety problem from doing so
but again the data are so
[ __ ] up that how would we know yeah
but the problem with that is that all of
these vaccines as different
as the two mrna vaccines are from the
adenovectored
vaccine they all function on exactly the
same principle
yes right and because they all function
on exactly the same principle it's not a
good test of whether or not
we are limiting our future options yeah
extreme vaccines
that's true um okay
would you use uh ivermectin prophylaxis
over vaccines when trying to have a
child to get pregnant
uh so you know we we are not doctors and
we are not providing medical advice
if i was
trying to get pregnant
i would prefer the ivermectin
this does raise uh a question
about this paper that we've been hearing
a lot about that we were going to try to
get to in the first hour that maybe we
should talk a little bit about here
i want to do that i want to say one
other thing first i believe we are
having
a uh what's the word
i don't know maybe it's a parallax
situation where
we've got multiple things impacting the
current sense of where we are pandemic
wise
and it is obscuring the things are
overlapping in a way that makes it hard
to know where we are
that was a very unclear way of saying
hey check this out
um i'll start again hey
check this out hey check this out um the
fact of the vaccines is clearly having
an impact on how many people are coming
down with covet
at the same time we are having an
unprecedented year
where people have been locked up afraid
cooped up in their houses
hanging out with the same people summer
is here in the northern hemisphere where
most humans live
people are clearly enjoying being out
and about and not wearing their masks
outside and
it's a whole different world out there
right that
takes us if this is exactly what we've
been saying on this podcast
which is most of the world because it's
outdoors
is safe you should be spending time
there you should be socializing there
you should be doing everything you can
to get as much normalcy in the outdoor
environment
as you can right people are doing that
now just instinctively
right okay
summer is not a forever phenomenon right
and so
the fact of kovid being much rarer at
the moment
is the result of two different things
and we don't know how to separate them
because they're happening at the same
moment
what does that have to do with pregnancy
what it has to do with
is you're going to love this because it
actually connects just crazy
like didn't we do the lockdowns question
no here's here's my point
if i was uh if i
identified as a woman sufficiently
strongly to
get pregnant and produce an offspring no
no
okay game over i think i'm leaving now
i'm sorry it's late
um stop okay were i a woman
and were i to get pregnant
now i wouldn't probably do
either i would behaviorally
isolate so that especially
because first trimester fetuses are so
much more fragile
that my sense is that you could
behaviorally protect yourself
really really well and it wouldn't be
easy or fun necessarily but it's a short
time window and that if you had to do
something downstream
i would if it were me i would probably
also choose the ivermectin because
it has we have better safety data but
it's not conclusive
for for fetuses but nonetheless
this is never on the table right we are
always given these weird stupid binary
choices
and the answer is actually producing a
child is you know
if not the most important thing you will
do in your life it is among them
right you should take it very very
seriously and if radical behavioral
modification in order to protect
yourself from covid without introducing
something foreign into your early
pregnancy
is a possibility for you based on how
your family functions where you live
whatever i would do that and summer is a
particularly good time to do it
because contact with covet is
comparatively rare because people are
outside
yep yep um
you know let's save the discussion of
that article
okay for next time so um
we we won't we won't have this clip but
we'll just say
um that there's there's this
uh zach which you can show briefly um
article preliminary findings of mrna
cover 19 vaccine safety and pregnant
persons
um which has been circulating for a
little bit and
has gotten a lot of people very hot
under the collar
about what it appears to suggest about
what it appears to find and obscure
about risk to
pregnant women's fetuses in the first
trimester when vaccinated
and we had never said anything about it
because we never read the paper
right so i finally read the paper
uh in preparing a response to the
quillette article
and um basically those people who think
this is um you know vaccination ending
level results are wrong they've mis
they've misunderstood what's going on
here um so it's um yeah there's a
confusing element in
there there's a there's they have
confusingly communicated some things in
this paper
um but the people who have imagined that
they found some smoking gun with regard
to
extraordinarily high miscarriage rates
post-vaccination are wrong they've also
done some bad math
um so we'll just leave it there for now
and
uh go back to the
next question let's see um
which means we don't know the answer i
should point out
with regard to whether or not they're
you know we we don't have a signal at
this point with regard to
how safe the vaccines are we
what are your thoughts on the finding of
graphene oxide in the mrna vaccines
well um my sense
is this is a case where something
extraordinary was
claimed i think on the basis
of a single vial that was claimed to be
analyzed and then there has been a claim
that the analysis was wrong
i don't know why graphene oxide should
have been in there it seems a very
bizarre
uh choice yeah um
and so i think the answer is
in general these kinds of claims turn
out to be false on the other hand
you and i are facing
claims that we are seeing mirages with
respect to
um the effectiveness of repurposed drugs
and other things and so i'm sure there
are lots of people looking on a kind of
a distance who think oh that's just
crazy
that's crazy talk and so i guess my
point here really is
we live in a world in which certain
crazy things are true
many crazy things in fact almost all of
them are false
and the job of you just eyeballing them
and figuring out which ones are true and
which ones are false
is uh it's a that's a fool's errand yeah
and so
i don't know how we deal with the fact
that you
next week we'll hear the next claim that
sounds absolutely preposterous and it
will almost certainly be wrong
right um and then you know to the extent
that you take the well if it's almost
certainly wrong i'm just going to assume
that the people saying it are nuts and
then people
point that at people who aren't nuts
right or you know
or you've got people on who you know are
largely making a lot of sense and maybe
they've made an error somewhere and
you know you you can't it's impossible
to end up having a conversation or to
be moving through life if um
you excuse me independently
seriously question every single claim
made by every single person that you're
engaging
yeah and so you know you come to trust
more of those people who
seem to be getting it right more often
than not yeah and you come to trust less
those people who more often than not are
getting things wrong
um either because they're not very good
at what they're doing or because they're
lying or
cynical or whatever it is it doesn't
matter if they're getting things wrong
more often than not you stop paying
attention to them you stop believing
them
but um you know even mostly wrong people
get things right sometimes and
even mostly right people get wrong
things wrong sometimes and
uh and
you know we're just most of us
are actually trying to do our best and
and get through this by making sense of
things
and uh we need to be forgiving of each
other's errors and emissions
yeah i mean as long as they're dealt
with honestly right
okay given the infuriating nature of
what's going on with covid and
ivermectin what advice can you
give to avoid becoming cynical about
humanity's fate
ah um it's bad for you
it's being cynical yeah i i mean this
because
it is quite possible to be cynical based
on
just sort of a normal extrapolation of
how much is wrong
and how much is headed in the wrong
direction
and the answer is okay well what would
that do for you
well actually it'll be paralytic or it
will turn you into a hedonist because
you'll think
there's no point in doing anything else
and i can guarantee you
as people who have not done that that if
you
imagine well i mean here's what i do
i do not know of a single reason that we
could not
turn this around right i know of a lot
of things that are wrong
i know of reasons to think it is
improbable that we will get enough
ducks in a row to actually turn things
around on the other hand you know i
remember the soviet union falling
i know that the cia didn't see it coming
i know that the rest of us didn't see it
coming
right i know that we elected barack
obama and although i was very
disappointed at
what he did in office i also know that
there was this sense of like okay
finally this is that new moment and and
anyway the point is
surprising interesting things happen as
he came into office yeah yeah
and you know as i've said before i still
like him as a guy i'm disappointed in
what happened i can't even explain most
of what happened under his presidency
but
but the point is if you
simply assume that until you have
very excellent reason to believe it
couldn't be turned around that
surprising things can emerge
and that what you want to do is be well
positioned to do something with them
then it will fill your life with meaning
and you will be
much happier and at some level if
you filled your life with meaning and
you were much happier and then it turned
out we didn't succeed in turning it
around
it would still have been a better use of
your time right so yeah yeah um
i would just take an approach like that
actually yeah
can the mrna vaccine cause oocytes to
produce spike proteins
are there fertility implications
i have no idea
you know i would have to go back to my
reproductive
biology i think my
instinct on that is no my instinct is no
too
based on the dormancy of them yeah so
maybe but if they were
um if they were
becoming active somehow like if they
were if they were if they were beginning
to move
and ready to be fertilized or something
well but so then i
mean i don't think so like we're just
totally guessing yeah yeah this is this
is not information you asked us to
guess and we're guessing um but um
reproductive implications are possible
because welcome to complex systems right
is this a likely mechanism uh i'm gonna
definitely look into it
but um both of our instincts are like uh
probably not
probably not that yeah yeah um
okay it seems to me that there is an
extremely strong pressure from motivated
reason
inherent to team vaccine's position on
safety for someone who's been vaccinated
it's not an abstract argument
his or her body is literally on the line
i can imagine being very resistant to
any conclusion that finds i may have
effectively poisoned myself
seems like an unusually strong source of
bias that might explain some of the
abstinence or apathy of many otherwise
smart people
towards any questioning of the vaccines
what do you think
so um yeah first of all i don't remember
what live stream it would have been
but i mentioned that i thought that this
was going to play an important role
yeah that um that the problem and i
believe me i actually
quite strongly empathize with it right
because
you and i um you know very early on
were enthusiastic about vaccines in this
case because we thought
maybe that's the way out of this right
and then you know from the beginning we
were concerned well we don't know what
the long-term impacts were
and that left us in a position of
looking at the evidence as it emerged
which frankly whether the evidence is
what it is or
it isn't what we think it is is scary
yeah
and so the point is that caused us to
actually go a different way
and not get vaccinated and so
the the point is i can very and you know
we were talking until actually pretty
late
in it that we thought we would
ultimately be forced to do it that the
risks were low enough
and that the advantages of just gonna
wait long enough see which one is the
is the best choice right so we thought
that was gonna happen so we can very
easily
imagine having done it and then feeling
like oh what is that signal
and you know god forbid you do have one
of these bad reactions
you know so anyway yes can totally
imagine it but given that
again we can't sorry but again we cannot
trust the data that we're seeing
but you know if if it's if this part of
it is true
it does seem that the most extreme you
know there may be very long-term effects
of course as we've been saying forever
and we cannot know
um but it does seem like um the effects
the the adverse events fall off
precipitously over time
post-vaccination and so the longer it's
been like if you
if you are very concerned the longer
it's been probably
the less likely you are to end up having
one of these adverse events
yes although i i don't know how to
deliver this message i think it's
implied in everything that we've talked
about but part of the problem here is
even if you're post-vaccine and even if
it went very very well
because we are not with a vaccine-only
approach
because we are not on a trajectory to
actually driving this pathogen to
extinction
however we ended up there the likelihood
that we are going to be dealing with
a never-ending sequence of variants and
therefore a never-ending sequence of
vaccine updates it's like a subscription
service
and so the point is if you got the
vaccine
and it went well that's good
you probably are getting a benefit from
it you're probably much less likely to
get covet and if you did get it it would
probably be much
less severe that's good on the other
hand
the question isn't really over because
the answer is well
what happens the next time and this is
why
the position of the vaccines are
wonderful and ivermectin doesn't exist
is so troubling is that it does not give
you
a tool that is potentially vital
in that mix a tool that from the point
of view of civilization's well-being
the evidence suggests might be a very
powerful contributor
to the branch of the tree that actually
gets us past
sars kobe 2. yeah so um
i would just say yes i think it is
contributing
but people ought to realize it isn't
like you know we were more or less
induced to believe it was going to be
you get the vaccine and we're done and
that's not how it's looking
and therefore one ought to think about
yourself as sort of
in one decision matrix
yep
nice one now i know what he thinks of it
what advice do you have to give others
when your credibility is attacked as
yours has been
we are here with you keep up the fight
that's a tough one yeah um
well a i will give a an observation that
we have made before
which is that this is very different
when
you have a reality check that you can
rely on
and reality check doesn't mean somebody
to tell you nice things it means
somebody to tell you what they see
yeah um and so you and i have been very
very lucky
that there's never been a moment in you
know the last four years
for us where we had to take the world's
input as to you know
what was happening to us we were able to
check it with somebody else who could
see it too
yeah i mean it's not that we haven't
disagreed like you know we have we have
not always seen
uh exactly the same thing um you know
starting you know
either when you know evergreen was
happening or this
um uh
and it hasn't always been easy but you
know the the
the disagreement between us about what
is actually happening
and you know what is true and what's not
and what is wrong and what's right
um is incalculably
valuable yeah it really is so um that's
that's exact that's the opposite of
advice like you know get yourself one of
those
um that's that's not operational um
at all but um you know conti
if if your credibility is attacked
and you have been doing the best
that you know to do and you're operating
in good faith
then you continue to know that and
it doesn't make it easy and you might
end up
capitulating
but it doesn't make you wrong like if
you if you oh if you 100
were doing the best that you could with
the information that you had and you
were operating in good faith and you and
you're sure of that
and again it helps if someone else is
watching you and being like
yeah that that okay wait that was a
little bit misstep whatever right
um then no matter
how many people show up and you know of
course the fact that it's anonymous
hordes on the internet
um in some ways makes it harder but in
some ways makes it easier too
because it's a you know now multiply
repeated observation
that people interact well are plenty
happy to interact
anonymously or at least with that
barrier online in ways that they would
never you know they would never say most
of those things to your face
right um but
you should still be able to go to sleep
at night going i'm doing the best
i know to do and trying to figure out
what is true and best for people
and uh and that that is going
that just helps it and frankly
trying to figure out what the motives of
the other people are and you know
it's a bad faith are they just dumb like
what is going on
that doesn't help us much and you know
it's necessary to the argument sometimes
it's necessary to try to understand like
how is it
that such and such a person can be so
savvy here and apparently not there is
it a lack of savviness is it lack of
general savviness or is it capture or
what is it
um but the like how do you deal with it
yourself
you know you you be good and then
you can as you're falling asleep at
night go like okay i'm still doing the
best i can
the haters gonna hate all right two more
things
on this topic i think
one is always caught it's
one has to be honest with themself in
order to navigate the following
difficult puzzle the puzzle is
you take flack
when you're wrong and when you're right
yeah and so there's this phrase that's
flack over the target
right right but if you but it's it
always
it worries me right that's the problem
is that you can if you take that
as an excuse to not listen to critique
that's a problem you will you will fool
yourself and so my point would be
that the only route out of that pickle
is to recognize a that flack over the
target
is one of a couple of explanations for
flak yeah
and two not being socially persuaded
is essential the crazier a social
environment a political environment
is the degree to which you are not
socially persuaded
of something you are analytically
persuaded dictates whether or not you
can navigate those two different kinds
of flack
and not be pushed off of yes you know
truth but be caused to alter your course
when you've misunderstood something
and it is an essential scientific skill
and it is a very rare
human skill because humans are so social
so we take the flack as an indicator of
danger and that translates to people
imagining that it must mean you're not
right when
it sometimes does and often does not yes
um
sorry i'm what we've been at it for like
50 minutes or so zach
did we okay really we didn't start until
5 30. okay
um let me
here we go let's let's do something and
now for something completely different
okay that's the best british accent you
can muster
no i i can i could do that but i'm not
i'm not going to
i'm not going to know yeah um and not
late enough
yeah well after five lots of places
actually it's after five exactly as many
places now as it always is
wow i know that's huge so not deep
are there any updates on unity or plans
for 2022 political action by you
i couldn't survive the gas enlightenment
without you two much love
i love this term yes enlightenment good
work so yeah
that's chop citizen that's that's our
french citizen yeah
yep chop citizen yeah yeah chop salad is
what i always hear
and then i catch up to chop citizen um
yes there's stuff afoot uh not ready
to reveal it yet um stay tuned
and prepare for a broadening of your
understanding
of unity because it's very easy to over
generalize from the first instance of
something you have seen
and you know the mission has to be
bigger oh this is exciting
yes okay um
enough i can't i'm not gonna do it now
no normally
normally i do it no the mainstream
opinion is that neutering your dog will
keep them healthy
keep them healthy reviewing the
literature suggests the opposite that
removal of the testes or ovaries
multiplies the risk of some chronic
diseases like bone cancers and diabetes
i am planning to adopt a dog soon and
hesitant to have him neutered what are
your thoughts
this is a complex one this is very
complex um
i mean it it is true that of course it
has
health effects right yeah in both
directions
um in both directions in in both
directions and it also has
behavioral effects and for the the boys
for the
for the boy critters um largely those
behavioral effects um
upon neutering are ones that people
prefer yes
it makes them more manageable yes
could you not yes also i'm sure that
would work with humans but
but we don't we don't do that um
yeah now in seriousness a
you may not have a choice um because of
the manageability of your critter
yeah um b i think the calculation isn't
really a longevity calculation although
i'm actually
not convinced yeah that it would if you
manage let's say so there's no
suggestion of longevity here
so in a male critter the
removal of male test uh tendencies by
removing the testes
could have some positive effects on
longevity
right yeah on the other hand it could
also have some like weight
increase which would have a negative
impact on longevity so
i think it isn't a simple question
yeah um but the real issue is you know
at some level if you
step outside of this and you say well
i'm
going to get this animal um i'm going to
provide this animal with a wonderful
gift which is a life as free of worry as
any creature gets to experience
and it will not be an infinitely long
life but it will be an
excellent life right and i'm taking
responsibility for the animal's
well-being throughout
that life and you know
at some level one has to you know does
having a
sexually intact frustrated animal serve
the animal's
interests not necessarily so
i would think about the calculation that
way and uh
yeah yeah good
can you identify and explain the key
skills that public education has not
distributed now contributing to our
collective sense making challenges
at one level i was thinking maybe we
should just punt this to the week that
we're talking about school
and education when we're talking about
our education chapter
um but if you've got a list right off
the top of your head i mean i think it
comes down to two things
two things two right and maybe they're
even
one the one would be first principles
thinking which it turns out
um even people who seem to do it local
to one
set of questions or topic yeah don't
always do it across the board
and don't know when they're not doing it
which is very dangerous
um there's a related phenomenon so i
don't want to
derail you but this related phenomenon i
think of like
oh i uh saw something
different or uncomfortable early and so
i'm heterodox
and um and now i view myself as one of
the heterodox people but it turns out
that that was either
an accident a lucky accident or i'm
really good
just in that domain but i don't have any
ability or interest in actually
challenging orthodoxy in any other
domain but i'm still going to claim the
mantle of heterodoxy and kind of stand
here and be like well i'm heterodox and
i know that those people
are being crazy now because i as a
heterodox person would clearly see
heterodoxy as valuable wouldn't i
and so if i don't think it's valuable it
must not be heterodoxy yeah so there's
that little
like trick that people are fooling
themselves with it is true and you know
you do
uh one thing i i thought to say
but then forgot during our uh main
discussion
was that crisis reveals everybody's
character yes this is one of the big
lessons of evergreen
so with regard to education you said you
think it comes down to two things it
might be one
yeah first principles thank you first
principles thinking and then the one
that might be rolled into first
principles thinking but i believe
deserves a special highlight
is extrapolation right what i find
is that sometimes it's possible to get
you know i think i think that's
it comes second but yeah um
and the and the maddening experience of
okay you've seen this thing
we agree on what it is now extrapolate
and it's like uh nope don't know what
you're talking about
you know i can't and it's like look
that's the problem is that
in order to figure out what's going on
extrapolating
responsibly is key now an extrapol i
mean so like the visual that i got
in my head uh when you were saying that
was actually it was like
zoom in zoom out like extrapolates like
a lateral like now apply that thing to
that thing of a similar scale
right but there's also like um a scalar
extrapolation
that is necessary of like can you having
figured out something at this scale can
you ever move across scales
can you go to this level or or closer in
and we all may have a place where we are
best
i'm not sure that's true but we all may
have a place where you know
you know given no constraints at all
about what we might be
thinking about and trying to solve
problems and it would be that scale over
and over and over again
um but extrapolation is like lateral
moves across domains
but scalar extrapolation within perhaps
the same domain
going from the micro to the macro and
and in and out
is another thing that people seem to
have and many people seem to have a very
difficult time with
yeah i like it it's one it's one type of
extrapolation that if you get good at it
it reveals a ton of stuff
um there's one that we've talked about
uh scientifically
which is um if you can find some
process in space it has an analog in
time and vice versa yeah
right that's a good one and then there's
the one that we started the main
uh live stream today with which is
if you can see that with a television
it's not the fact of the television it's
the business model that creates the
content yeah and then you can say oh
that applies to my phone that applies to
porn and does it apply to
pharmaceuticals that's the question
right um and once you've seen that and
then
and then the next time you see one of
these realms you'll
know how to at least start not from zero
but from
a is this one of those places that yeah
yeah yeah
no that's good that's good um
okay um
i'm not sure what this one means um
baffled why the organ transplant
specialists aren't willing to
investigate ivermectin
as johns hopkins study is showing 17
percent effective with vaccine
maybe that means organ transplants are
17 effective
with vaccinated people without having
the comparison number i have no idea
what to make of that and
i don't know if that's what that number
means and i don't without a comparison
number like how many organ transplants
are affected without the vaccine
it's not that high i don't think so
um no i think it's way above 17. i mean
i guess it depends what we're talking
about no i didn't mean it's not that
high i meant it's you know
it's not like organ transplants are 100
successful right i
assume it's a hell of a lot higher than
17 percent um but again i'm not even
sure i'm interpreting
right now i don't get i don't get the
relationship yeah
are they saying that for vaccinated
people
organ transplants are more effective
given ivermectin i
can't figure out what the connection
yeah yeah
how can we separate adverse vaccine
reactions from the noise at this point
if we are being told that every adverse
effect is not
probably vaccine related how can we find
out
well this is actually this is the kind
of thing that
uh a high quality analysis
reveals it's precisely the kind of thing
i mean that work that
i was talking about in the first in the
main live stream
with regard to the deaths that happened
after adverse reactions to vaccines none
of which were the first 250 deaths none
of which were attributed to
the vaccines all of which were
attributed to covid um that work was
extraordinarily carefully done and
that's exactly
you know i didn't want and it was very
conservative and it was very
conservative and that's how you
that's that's the kind that's what you
need to do you know you need to be
conservative in
in your in your analysis and your
results well
in this case we have a
complex puzzle because what we're
talking about
is is the signal of hazard strong enough
that one should put the brakes on a
process that has a known upside
right and so the question of
what is what does conservative look like
does conservative look like being very
careful and not deploying the vaccine
until you're very very sure it's quite
safe
or does it look like not impeding the
distribution of the vaccine until you're
very very sure it's harmful i wasn't
talking about policy proposals being
conservative i was talking about
research right right
well but the point is you can do this in
the analysis and you can say
this analysis aired in this direction
for this reason it is
these case and in fact that analysis did
it it said here we've got a bunch of
cases in which we have
uncertainty and then we've got these
cases in which it's very probable that
these are the results right that's right
and so anyway that's the right way to to
do it and then you're right the policy
layer
goes on top of that yeah yeah so i mean
it's it's doable we have we have the
methods
you know yeah this is going to sound
glib but it's called science and there's
just
unfortunately a lot of stuff that's not
science that's being you know
painted with the word science and tried
it out in some kind of science
of marketing in sciences clothing
clothing
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
blockchain question are you concerned
about the permanence of blockchain in
relation to odyssey it being impossible
for users to remove their own content
um it's an issue one can remove
content from active
from it being found
um i'm more concerned about this not
from the point of view of people like us
who are putting
content up of a normal sort but that if
you know i think it's the point eric
makes very clearly
if somebody doxes you for example right
and they put
content up that shouldn't be up because
you have a right to keep your address
private or whatever
the fact that it could be resurrected by
somebody is a real problem and i do
think
you know we ought to talk about those
cases where something that we all agree
is not somebody's right to put up
can't be removed from the web for for
blockchain reasons so yes
it's a real question yep okay
um four four last questions
none of them about coven yeah can you
believe it
uh jordan peterson discusses that
spirituality evolved with humanity and
is essential what do you think um
yeah you gotta define terms a little
better but i think we agree with
with his point right and so the question
is
yes it's essential does that mean a
spirituality of a named kind does it
mean somebody can invent a replacement
does it mean
you know i would argue because i mean
it's essential for every human being
right um but to the extent that we
don't have a spirituality which is up to
date enough to deal with modernity
um we are in a damned if you do damned
if you don't situation and the question
is how do you bootstrap
a something that serves that need
without putting us in conflict with each
other because you know
my god disdains your god or whatever um
it's an it's it's a vital question one
of the most vital questions
all right um lovely to see you two again
what happened to privacy can it make a
comeback which animal is the most
private
thank you for being here that was one
question
yeah um
what happened to privacy
it got curb stomped while we were
busy looking at our cool new phones yeah
um
yeah that was the phones yeah it was the
phones we bugged ourselves
yeah we bugged ourselves and then some
number of people invited
um alexa bugs and such into their homes
and yeah putting up with cameras on
streets
the problem with the privacy question
for animals yeah
is that it would be possible to
succeed in answering the question
without delivering anything satisfying
by picking some incredibly solitary
animal yeah
we could get somewhere near something
interesting with wolverines
which are um wide
far-ranging giant home ranges giant home
runs distinction between a home range
and a territory being the home range is
all of the geography that you ever cover
and your territory is that part of the
geography that you've recovered that you
defend
many organisms everyone has a home range
many organisms don't have territories
yeah
and i don't remember actually um what
all is the story
if like male wolverines are also
territorial or females are also
territorial or they really aren't at all
except maybe during mating season
yeah i think very limited towards
territoriality
temporarily limited that it has to do
with um
winter carcasses their niche is very
heavily focused on things like a moose
who has died somewhere and so ranging so
they're just like
they're like carcass territorial it's
not even like you know wherever the
thing died they're gonna defend that
thing
for until it's until its meat is gone
right something like that
yeah um i will say the problem is
does private privacy mean totally
solitary or could it be
like my one of my favorites when we go
to uh
to the amazon um i remember the amazon
you remember the amazon i do remember
the night monkeys yeah
night monkey is an amazing creature uh
owl month they're one of your favorites
well i really like the yellow monkeys um
and the owl monkeys
they're monogamous and they live in
these little holes and trees and you
wouldn't
think anything of it to look at the hole
when it's daytime and they're
there's no activity of these animals
this is the only nocturnal
the only uh anciently nocturnal
monkey there's a monkey that has a
driven nocturnal
by human hunting but this is the only
one that and there are a couple of other
primates
yeah there's lots of problems yeah we
don't we don't use the word prosimone
anymore well i apparently still did
um yes among the prostimian primates
like lemurs and things they're not going
to persist
what am i supposed to call them
i can't remember it's uh it's uh look
i'm going to call them
i can't remember it's the flight is it
the haplorhines the straps are i can't
remember and i can't remember
okay so among the what we used to call
the what we used to call the prosimian
primates right the
lemurs and tarsiers and bush babies and
all that stuff
and the problem actually i think is the
tarsiers it is the tarsiers jumped
clades
they they're out yeah yeah now we are
understanding of where the tire series
are jumped
and that just through all of our naming
system into not only
this is what you were hoping for right
this question only did our understanding
of where the tar sears are jumped but
the tarsiers themselves jumped it's what
they do best yeah they do that
really really well and they don't even
know all the chaos that they're creating
over the
guide looks primates systematics land
they have no idea they would be quite
delighted if they knew but they don't
know
yeah they're kind of private they're a
little private yeah i mean all nocturnal
creatures almost all nocturnal creatures
are a bit private or is that just our
diurnal bias like they're private we
never see them nope i know the answer to
this one
um a large fraction of what drives
nocturnality is crypsis yes um
because light is cheap and so we'll be
talking about this in a couple weeks
sleep chapter there you go yeah so
anyway the point is
there's a tendency amongst nocturnal
creatures therefore
to be uh
things are falling in the other room um
to sex like can we
anyway so i would say there's something
very lovely
about owl monkey privacy
because they huddle in their little tree
hole together with their family
and then they emerge you know if you go
to their tree
as night falls you can actually watch
them emerge and it's very predictable
very hard to get a picture i will tell
you but very predictable
oh hello um and
anyway so that they are very private uh
in their own way but they are private
together and
i don't know that's cool yeah that's
cool it is cool
all right um we got two questions
about food and next week's chapter from
hunter-gatherers guide is the food
chapter
so let's just get a jump on talking a
little bit about food and then maybe
maybe we'll encourage each week i wanted
to say like we're going to
prioritize questions about whatever
topic was from the book this week but um
there's been a lot of other stuff going
on so there has been a lot of other
stuff going on
but um yeah so actually we're gonna
answer one of these next week and i will
forward the other one so that it will
definitely be answered next week okay
so the um traveling with the severe food
allergy especially the language barrier
we're going to
start out with next week okay so i'm
going to forward that i'm saying that
out loud so if it doesn't happen
we'll know there's a problem in the
system and um
i will get back to it but we're going to
finish on
do you have any thoughts on seed oils
and zen estrogens in the modern diet
seeking info on these just made me feel
crazy thanks
yeah so this is this what i'm
i'm at a loss on this one oh um well so
i mean seed oil is
you know avocado oil and coconut oil and
all of this and then
um boy the zen estrogens are things like
soy
basically yeah um and
he's got a question yeah he has a
question we never answer his questions
um i mean
the short answer is the less processing
that was done
to move it from a food an organism that
you would recognize as an organism into
the food that you're eating the more
likely it is
to be relatively healthy for you to eat
that's not a perfect answer because you
know
sugars for instance just just aren't
good for us
and um you know sucking on sugar cane is
better than
um putting sugar in your coffee
but it's still just not not good for you
so um
the some
of the zen estrogens uh
do seem to be able to um
go through an aromatization process in
our bodies and thus have hormonal
effects
and um and that's not a great thing but
it seems
pretty to be a pre what you're just
what there's a great joke here but i
can't make it
without getting canceled you're
cancelled you're going to get cancelled
now over a
sec joke if i pointed out that your
claim
that seed oils can aromatize
causing hormonal effects and that
suggests that they
could become trans fats
i'm done right if i said that out loud
yeah yeah
i'd be canceled yeah even though i don't
think there's anything
there's nothing offensive about that
joke nonetheless i will be canceled for
it so that's why i'm not saying it out
loud you're not saying it out loud yeah
um yeah i mean i guess you know so the
other food question
i think we can riff on forever and i
probably should have taken that one
given that we're really tired right now
um i don't i don't have a great answer i
think
um you know even
so olive oil has been in um culinary
production for thousands of years
it seems avocado oil has not
avocados um have been eaten for a very
long time
and so you know an avocado is an awesome
thing
and olives are an awesome thing and
turning olives into olive oil
and using that to cook with with its
thousands of years old history is almost
certainly
awesome but then what a few years ago we
start to be told well you know olive oil
has too low a smoke point you don't want
to be cooking with it you want to be
cooking with avocado oil instead and
like
like well okay but in order if in order
to get that smoke point up
you have to mess with it a lot and you
have to do some fancy things in your lab
i don't want any part of that i'd rather
cook more carefully and you know i'll
use
butter for god's sake or ghee right um
so
you know we we use actually a
combination of
you know olive oil and coconut oil and
and avocado oil and butter
and those are pretty much it um to cook
with owen you know i always save the fat
from bacon
and use that whenever you know if we
have it cooking potatoes or eggs or
something and that's just
you know free flavor right there bacon
did someone say bacon
[Laughter]
uh but i i guess that's it you know
the higher a heat to which it's been
processed and if it is claiming that
it's you know it's
you can cook it at a higher heat than
you can other versions of the same
species oil it's probably it's probably
had some stuff done to it that is
rendering it um a bit more
dangerous speaking of dangerous
i think i think he's now seeing himself
in the screen and wondering
what is happening well
do you have anything to add that was a
ridiculous answer but
i think your uh your rubric is is right
um i'm definitely going to look up a
connection between
the seed oils and the estrogens
and see what i can find out
um but all right are we there i think
we're at the end of this very long
yeah i think we're there so we will be
back um on saturday
with episode 88 yes and uh and
you know all all the usual stuff join
our patreon subscribe to the channels
um buy a goliath shirt um
at either of our patreons you can get
access to the discord server where there
is apparently a lively ongoing
conversation
um you should feel free to email
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com with
logistical concerns or questions
and until we see you next and ongoing
after that
be good to the people you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you